[Music] According to
the story of a warrior, the
earl who changes flights seems to enjoy drinking wine while looking at the moon before going to bed
above all else.
Earl Karl has a perfectly round
face If Seth isn't there,
I'm gradually losing my mind
I
'm an assassin just like in my previous life Ah,
but this time
it's not just the eastern part of the city I
've decided that I can't kill or not kill
[MUSIC]
Confirm the target
A maid of a certain family
Eliminate the assassin aristocrat based on the beliefs of Wahaha
[MUSIC]
Mission complete,
withdraw
Yes Rule-
sama Custom I
was not moved by the act of killing.
I used to be a tool
But now I
'm taking [music] Somehow
Master Dave looked helpless Did he look like that
[music]
I'm sorry Let's go
Louvais is gorgeous